hey on today's show we're going to talk
about adult themes and so be
sensitive and be careful for the young
ears in the room
i also want to point out that we take
live calls and we often don't know where
they're going to go and so today's show
can feel kind of jarring
we talk about family boundaries around
the holidays and it's fun it's
light-hearted i'm being silly and then
we get into a couple of calls that are
really hard they're also about
boundaries
about setting boundaries with addicts
about setting boundaries with
abuse stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up i'm jon and this
is the dr john deloney show
it's a live show where we show up and
walk alongside people who are struggling
folks who are trying to do the next
right thing and fellow human beings who
are learning how to be human beings
again we talk about everything on the
show anything and everything
no matter what's going on in your heart
in your mind in your family in your
workplace
there are so so many people across your
state
across your country across the world who
are going through
very similar things and it just takes
one person to be brave
one person that just reaches out and
says i don't know what to do
and you're gonna help so many other
people and on this show we talk about
falling in and out of love
we talk about loss we talk about family
issues
scratching and clawing for hope
we may even talk about hey here's the
deal this weekend
this happened um if you're not a hunter
just hit the little forward button a
couple of times and pass this
my son and i went squirrel hunting this
weekend and we
we eat the squirrels and i know that
makes us weird like we are from the
1400s but it is what it is
we are hunting squirrels and i got a
squirrel
and i was cleaning the squirrel my
daughter showed up
and she's four and a half and she looked
at it
or she's almost five now and she was
like
but she likes to eat them and so
we talked about the cleaning process and
we were just having a regular
conversation well that night
we do a bed pile we read books and
stories
and then we turn the lights off
and i tell my daughter hey i love you
have a great sleep
i hope you have great dreams and as i
was walking out of
the room she says daddy this is pitch
black and i turn and say
yeah baby and she said and i quote
you know that squirrel doesn't forgive
you right
so awesome and i said honey you are
right that squirrel is not going to
forgive me
so we're going to talk about everything
on this show um you know we're going to
talk about family
so um before i get going on family give
me a call 1-844-693-3290
that's 1-844-693-3291
or email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john john ramsey
solutions.com
all right so i want to start today's
show not going directly to the phones
i want to talk about holidays this
holiday season
is going to be bananas but it's also a
gift and i'm going to tell you why it's
a gift
um shortly here but one of the biggest
frustrations i have
is when folks pretend that the holidays
just appear out of the mist that they
don't come on the same day every year
that you can't plan for them that you
can't expect the same conversations over
and over again
and it might be financially it might be
about money
right that how many times have we got to
mid-november and we're like oh my gosh
i can't afford christmas presents or it
gets to be december 15th and you're like
i don't have any money left and i gotta
buy eight presents for fill in the blank
that shouldn't surprise you that
shouldn't surprise you that means you're
not
living an intentional life it means you
may be out of control if you're not
planning ahead right
and even 10 bucks a month over the
course of
12 months and you got 120 bucks to buy a
couple of gifts for a couple of people
right
but that's number one but the bigger
challenge is
that we pretend that the same holiday
feelings aren't going to show up every
year
that suddenly we're gonna go to this
same christmas eve event that we've gone
to for 15 years or 20 years or 30 years
and that same uncle isn't going to pull
us aside and make the same
incredibly offensive ethnicity jokes
or that same grandma isn't going to
try to pull your cheek off of your face
or that same granddad
isn't going to corner you and start
hammering you on politics and who you
voted for and i can you believe that the
fill in the blank we just pretend that
those things
aren't gonna happen this year and we may
think they're gonna happen but we
just always end up completely
psychologically and emotionally
unprepared for the
the aftermath for the fallout for that
dark plane ride home
or that silent sadness trip
that we the you know you and your new
husband and
your dogs or you and your older wife
and your kids you'll just drive back and
it's that icky weird like
here's the thing you got a gift called
kovid this year
and i know it's awful to call it a gift
but i'm trying to find the silver lining
folks so go with me on it
here's the thing we have an opportunity
to change
traditions we have an opportunity to
speak up and be heard
in a way that we haven't before
millions and millions of us have dealt
with financial challenges have dealt
with employment challenges have dealt
with transportation challenges have
dealt with
mobility challenges some states if you
leave you got a quarantine for 14 days
before you come back you can't just
leave for a weekend and
hop back into your same life and so i
want to talk about how to set
family boundaries during the holidays
and i want everyone listening
all 33 people of all 33 of you right who
are
mowing your lawn or riding your bike or
cleaning your house or driving to work
whatever it is
how you might be listening i want you
all of us i want all of us
to to agree right now that we're going
to set holiday boundaries
okay so here here's a couple of things
we can do to set boundaries number one
you remember that you y-o-u
are in control of your schedule before
you commit to travel or hosting plans
you decide what your limit is three days
two weeks if you're married or you're
gonna be traveling with a boyfriend or
girlfriend sit down and co-create a plan
together
this is how many days we are staying
this is when we are going to leave
and then you are going to announce those
plans to somebody else whether it be
your mother your dad your
in-laws the multiple in-laws you have to
go to
your dad's new wife and your mom's
ex-husband
whoever you're going to you decide you
set the schedule
you determine it and by the way don't
drive or fly
thousands of miles to a place that's
inhospitable or threatening
just say no just say this year hey we're
not gonna we're not traveling
and don't lie and say well we can't this
year but you could
just say i'm not gonna come this year
i'm going to send gifts instead i hope
we can all facetime
here's what we're going to do but you
set your boundaries
be honest about it stand up tall about
it
and listen if you do go and you say i'm
going to show up for three days
do not go and whine the entire time
you're there
that's like bringing poison to the group
that makes you the problem
it's a waste of energy it's a waste of
time it just brings
everybody's moments down if you're gonna
go go with a smile on your face
go with joy in your heart right if you
are so selfish that you cannot honor
your grandparents with the night free
from beer and cell phones
if you'll just comb your hair with a
part for one night tuck your shirt in
honor and respect him nah dude that's
not me bro i gotta be true to myself
shut up dude honor your grandparents or
don't go
don't go you play dress-up on friday
back when we used to be able to go to
concerts and you'd get all dolled up for
whatever concert you were going to dudes
you'd be like i've got my leather pants
and my
my cool my cool boots or whatever it is
i don't know what you got dressed up
but you can get dressed up for concerts
you can get dressed up for dates you can
pretend for a night or two with your
grandparents you can pretend for a night
or two with your parents
dress up alright so number two decide
beforehand what you won't tolerate
and stick to it for example thanksgiving
is just a couple of weeks after the
election
i'm hoping we have a president by then
we might not if you don't want to talk
about politics
send an email beforehand that says
we will not discuss politics this will
be a politics free
thanksgiving period we will not talk
about it
and if somebody violates your boundaries
when you're there walk
out or ask for a guest list of who's
going to be there
and if someone says hey i want to take a
bunch of pictures of your kids say
no you cannot take pictures of my child
and post them on social media if that's
not what you want if you don't mind that
then rock and roll
or if you have a alcoholic relative who
puts you and your family in danger when
they're drunk or they make everything
weird
you say no and here's the thing just
walk out
just walk out and if you have situations
where somebody's not safe and you can't
afford a hotel room so in case you have
to leave
then don't go don't go you get to own
you okay number three have a plan when
things
escalate what we're just talking about
if somebody
um always wants to front hug real tight
and they start coming in
every year they're front hugging uncle
uncle whoever
you can say stop please i don't like
that
or that one uncle guys who always grabs
you by the
by the neck or behind the ear you can
look at them and firmly say
hey stop grabbing me please be
direct have a few phrases ready to go
please stop hugging and kissing my kids
period
and if she keeps doing it or he keeps
doing it leave right
if uncle whoever um won't stop talking
bad about a particular group of people
people who don't look like you from
different religions than you different
geographic locations in you
you can look them in the eye and say
please stop
please don't talk about that group in
front of my family like that thank you
and if they continue this my house i can
talk to i want to
bye felicia i'm out i'm going to leave
see you later and it doesn't have to be
dramatic and it's not a big
stomp out you know why because you're a
grown-up just gonna take your kids and
say
you'll have a great night and we'll see
you tomorrow or thank you so much and
we're gonna head back and then you and
your family
can have a nutrition night off and just
eat ice cream until your brains come out
all right um whatever it is set your
boundaries and then have a plan for when
things escalate and here's number four
going back to the grandparents thing
understand your role
if you're a guest at someone else's
house recognize that you don't have the
same authority
as you might in your own house if you
are a boyfriend
or a girlfriend or you're visiting your
in-laws
keep in mind that you can respect their
home
be a person of dignity right
if you are uh going with somebody to
their
parents house for thanksgiving whether
you're married to them or you're just
visiting y'all just dating
that's not about you it's about them so
if your father and they'll ask you to do
some weird thing
if your mother-in-law asks you to you
know get on the roof
on the hou on the house and i mean on
the roof and re-roof the house or
hey tonight we're gonna go do a weird
family thing where we
i don't know fill in the blank with
whatever weird things your family does
just say cool i'm in or if it violates
your boundaries just say
i'm gonna step out tonight i'm gonna
head to hotel you'll have a great fun
time don't make a scene don't be
dramatic about it
but understand your role and if you
can't pretend
if you can't dress up if you can't honor
your parents and your grandparents
for one night for two nights god help
you man just don't go
just don't go and make the holidays the
moment when you
yeah yeah show them do that enough do
that in july
okay and here's a note to um parents of
adult children
this is for parents out there if your
kids can't travel to see you because of
finances and other plans
let them off the hook of course you want
to see your grandkids
of course you do of course you
have missed out on everything because of
covid
of course you've been nervous and scared
and lonely
but beating up and guilt-tripping your
adult children helps nobody
it puts them in situations that they
can't deal with
financially it puts them in stressful
emotional situations
be the grown grown grown grown-ups and
you might have to let go of that fantasy
and that picture you had of this
gathering this special meal this photo
by a tree
and you're gonna have to create a new
picture for what holidays are going to
look like this year
if your kids can't make it choose
beforehand you're not going to talk bad
about them you're not going to guilt
trip them but you're going to
immediately go into
what's a new picture mode we're going to
have a
we had to do my mom's 70th birthday this
year via zoom
was it ideal nope was it hilarious and
fun yup
ended up being a blast right whatever
the new thing is going to look like this
year
go for it everybody be adults everybody
be compassionate with one another
this is the year to come up with new
boundaries
this is the year to come up with new
traditions this is the year to double
down
on respect and dignity and
honoring one another instead of like
yeah dude i always wear my leather pants
and no shirt to
holidays that's got to be me dude stop
quit
look around the world man that kind of
nonsense is killing us all be cool
be cool right good okay that's my that's
my discussion on
family boundaries at the holidays let's
all agree we're going to love each other
through the holiday season
it's going to be hard it's going to be
cold it's going to be a mess we're going
to have just
got off the heels of the election it's
going to take all of us to be grown-ups
all of us to love each other and to
smile for crying out loud all right
let's go to the phones let's go to
may in cincinnati ohio
what's up mei how are we doing
hey dr john how are you so good so good
how is cincinnati
ah chilly that's
if you live above oklahoma for the next
four months the
the normal response is cold chilly
dark so anyway that's awesome okay so
how can i help today may
okay so um i was calling a couple years
ago
my husband
my parents died in a car accident hey
take a breath take a breath
and um he has chosen to cope with
alcohol
oh man i'm so sorry
[Music]
i'm trying to collect myself sorry no
you're good so while you're doing that
i'll i'll restate it so
a couple of years ago your husband's
parents tragically died
was it a car wreck yes okay so they
died suddenly and out of the blue in a
car wreck and
your husband has chosen to cope with
that with
alcohol that's been his his
numbing methodology of choice over the
last few years right
yes and it has started to spiral out of
control
yeah remember coming up on three years
i'm just starting to feel
really resentful of him
tell he just really checks out
and i don't know how to to deal with all
these feelings i have
so talk to me about him you said i feel
resentful i want you to verbalize
for me what is that what is that what
does resentful mean
um he works and he drinks and that is
about the extent of his day
yeah um he comes home he just he
disconnects from me he does connect from
the kids
he doesn't really engage with us he
doesn't help me around the house
i have begged pleaded cried
for him to get help to to help me
and he's just he just doesn't hear me he
would rather just
drink and spend time on his phone and
just
shut down
so i'm going to ask a couple of probing
questions okay and you can you don't
even have to go into them you can just
yes or no okay i'm trying to get a full
picture of
your husband here has he been faithful
all three years
um about a year ago i found him
found out he was talking to other women
online okay
has he ever been with any of them he
says no
okay and none of them were local so i i
doubt it
okay um is he going to work
is he staying is he he's drinking
uh his drinking hasn't taken over the
point that he's not going to work
anymore right
no he goes he's probably hungover or
maybe he's still drunk but he goes
okay tell me about his parenting is he
engaged with your kids or is he just
completely checked out
it's completely checked out okay how old
are your kids
uh well they're his kids my kids are
grown
okay um they're 14 and 15. okay
and how long have you all been married
um about 13 years
13 years tell me about the man he was
before this
before the accident
um honestly it's really
hard to there's like
it's just been so much that it's really
hard to remember all the good things but
it's
so deep in resentment at this point
he was more engaged um with the kids and
as the family
he drank but it was casually
and then he never grieved this never
never
dug into his feelings about his
appearance and and worked through this
he just checked out huh
yeah okay so
i'm gonna give you some hard truth okay
and i'm gonna be as
honest with you as i can at the same
time as compassion as i can
because they're only words that can
describe the situation
this just sucks and i hate this for you
and this your second marriage is that
right
no it's my first your first marriage
okay but you have other grown kids
yeah my kids are older yeah okay
um yeah this sucks so here's the thing
resentment is the nails in the coffin of
a relationship
it is very very hard to come back from
resentment
and if somebody's sitting in front of me
and they are
having to choose between anger and rage
and resentment i'll take anger and rage
seven days out of the week i mean seven
days yeah seven days a week
because resentment is so hard to come
back from it's just poison
and it's also not unfounded right the
guy you married
a decade in experienced a life-altering
tragedy and he disappeared on you
right i want you to as much as you can
get out of his head and get out of his
heart
because that's gonna kill you literally
okay
why he's doing what he's doing is feels
personal and it feels
like it's an attack on you and if he's a
true
debilitated alcoholic it probably has
little to nothing to do with you
okay he's got a whole bunch of demons
he's trying to keep at bay
does that make it right no is it
ridiculous yes
is it killing everybody in your house
yes but
you getting in his head and trying to
figure out why he's doing this
i wish he was doing this if he would ju
that's only beating you
up it's not solving any of your problems
and so you've got to make a plan there
is no relational healing while
somebody's
an alcoholic there just isn't
there is no way people get well until
people get sober
because you're not dealing with the
person you're dealing with the shadow of
a person
and this goes to people who work 120
hours a week and someone wants to fix
their marriage
then they gotta stop because they're
addicted to busyness
and folks who are addicted to fill in
the blank
pornography drugs alcohol whatever the
addiction is whatever the numbing
behavior is
they have to stop that for a period of
time before any relational healing can
happen
and so what i'm telling you is you are
now in a place
three years later this isn't a phase
this has become a way of life
your kids deserve better than this you
deserve better than this
and your husband deserves better than
this right
he is admits despair and that sucks
but until he decides through his own
heart that he wants to get well
then your relationship is going to be
what your relationship is
and so what you have to do is you've got
to start making decisions for yourself
and that's going to look like getting
some people that you trust in your life
that will sit down with you
walk alongside you whether that's an
intervention with your husband
whether that is you saying i'm going to
move out for 30 days until you decide to
get yourself well
whether that is you deciding this is
just going to be what this is for the
next five or six years until the kids
graduate whatever that happens to be
but resentment is it's just like the old
aaa saying resentment is poisoning
yourself and hoping he's gonna die
you're the one that's bearing the brunt
of that resentment and those kids not
him
and so when you think about um
if if you were to move out tomorrow or
you were to ask him to move out tomorrow
does that give you relief and peace in
your heart or does that make you real
anxious
and angry and frustrated anxious
why why does it make you feel anxious
because it feels like it's just removing
him from the
situation where he would probably just
be able to drink in peace and i'd still
have
all the responsibilities because i don't
know that he would be capable of taking
care of the kid
and do you hear that language that
you're talking about you've got to
got to make peace with that
you are the only one taking care of
those kids and it's going to be that way
for the foreseeable future
and the longer you lean into i have to
take care of these kids
and it's because of him you're literally
poisoning yourself
okay you're gonna have to change the way
you talk to yourself that voice inside
your own head
because the chemical response of your
body is poisoning you
you just are living off cortisol and
adrenaline for the last two or three
years
my guess is you probably haven't had a
chance to grieve either because you've
been trying to
keep a duct-taped house together right
have you met with somebody have you ever
sat down with a counselor and just says
here's my last couple of years
i started to yeah um
probably about a year ago okay and she
really just like honed in on his
drinking
and like how i needed to get him help
and i didn't that's
helpful listen that's a crappy therapist
dude because you can't help somebody
like that all you can help is you
right and so i want to
tell you that your therapist didn't do a
good job and
there's somebody out there in your local
community that's going to be great
okay and so i want to encourage you to
go again because you're at the plan
making stage now
you are at the what is going to be next
for me because now i'm living with
a alcoholic who was a functional
alcoholic and now he's disappearing
because the next step is he's going to
skip a day at work
and then he's going to not go back the
next day and then he's going to stop
being employed
this is just a trajectory now okay
okay and the older your kids get they're
absorbing
every second of that tension every
second of that resentment and you're
gonna have to do the best you can to
double down on how much you love them
make sure you are touching their face
every day i want you to hold their face
every day and tell them that you love
them
tell them how grateful you are that you
get to be their mom
i want you to plan and then you're
exhausted i know
but i want you to plan dates with them
i want you to just go pick up donuts
every once in a while and i think eating
donuts
is terrible but there's just some joy
right nothing a little carbs and sugar
can't take the edge off of
i want you to find joy and
giving them laughter and i want you to
find joy and giving them connection
because that connection and laughter is
going to heal you too
but until you let him off and he's out
you got to just
begin setting up each morning without
him in the picture because he's gone
okay i have a hundred percent
faith in redemption i've just known too
many former alcoholics who completely
turned around
and sometimes it takes an intervention
sometimes it takes rock bottom sometimes
it takes filling
any number of blanks but i do know this
about addiction the only person that can
help somebody
get well with alcohol is them they have
to make that decision and then they got
to seek out a community
that's going to walk alongside them for
the rest of their lives
and that's going to involve dealing with
your parent his parents death that's
going to involve
dealing with the pain of this marriage
that's going to
i mean that's going to be a lot of
adventures he's gonna have to walk
through
and if you're by his side oh that'd be
so beautiful be great
but also you need to live in the reality
that
you're living with an addict and your
relationship will not get well until he
chooses
to to get himself well and until you
choose to get yourself well
and you are living on bitterness and
rage right now resentment
is that fair i think some of yeah that's
right i think some of it is like we've
had
conversations where i've confronted him
on the drinking maybe confronted the bad
word but
like you talked with him about it and he
like acknowledges it
that it's a problem and it's causing
issues in their marriage and then
what he does now is he hides it from me
right and
and he continuing to challenge him on
the drinking is futile
i want you just to stop doing that it's
not helpful okay
it's not going to change um if he knew
how to be connected with you if he knew
how to fully be loved by you
if he knew how to grieve the loss of his
parents
and to grieve the loss of his innocence
and how to be a father who's
totally present with his teenage kids he
wouldn't need
alcohol and if he was able to process
childhood traumas that existed he would
need to numb that out and so he can't
and so
um at this point beating him up about it
isn't helping
that drives it underground like you just
said
and so what he needs is you to love him
but you also you need to begin to love
you
and you need to begin to honor yourself
and
those kids and that starts with you
healing from the inside out
and you cannot do that by yourself and
you can't do it with an addict so you're
going to have to go get a counselor
you're going to have to get a group of
women in your community that you can
trust
you can sit with not for griping and
whining sessions
but for sessions where they can just
hear your feelings hear your pain
sit with you and then walk with you as
you begin to
heal from that healing may look like
therapy it may look like you being
really intentional about
a workout program and a nutrition
program
it may look like you being really
intentional about being a hyper
connected parent doubling down on those
kids and loving them
it may look like you journaling and
doing gratitude work every single day so
you begin to shift your default setting
from one of resentment and
that piece of crap who's just sitting on
the couch dragging this boat under water
you cut that rope you cut the rope he's
not going to anchor you down anymore and
then you're going to rise above it so
but that starts with you honoring
yourself and
my my opinion is you need to get a
counselor you can find a new counselor
it's not going to spend all your money
and your time talking about somebody
else who's going to talk about you
and what you can do to get well and then
you run from there so
may thank you so much for the call
that's a hard one man because there's
not an easy solution
and you're on a long long journey that's
why i just started the whole call with
saying this sucks because you're in it
now
um but we'll be thinking about you if
you decide to make some major
transitions if you decide to
have an intervention with his friends
and his family if you decide to
um go see somebody call me back let me
know how your
your walk and your journey is going and
um i'll be here to help
thank you so much for the call all right
let's go to lauren in seattle lauren how
are we doing
uh pretty good how are you i'm doing
well i'm doing well how can i help this
morning
um well my question's about boundaries
and how to cope if
people or a person a particular person
won't respect those boundaries
so my father was sexually abusive when i
was a child
and i i hadn't really told anyone as
like as a kid but i knew that
whenever i was an adult that and i had
some power that
i would do something about it and that
he
wouldn't be able to do anything to us
anymore so now as an adult
my husband and i have set up boundaries
for him but he doesn't really respect
those we've moved the boundaries further
and further away just to protect our
kids
because if he's already stepping over
the boundary we want to make sure that
that stepping over doesn't affect our
children um
but now at this point we've moved him
far enough away that he's supposed to
not be contacting us at all
um but he still does and then he's
getting
more sneaky about it so he'll write us
letters but not put a return address on
it or
try to get my brothers to contact us um
so
this has been going on for about five
years so i'm not really sure
if we can expect him to ever change or
if maybe there's something that we can
i don't know that i can implement to
help me cope it it really bothers me a
lot
yeah whenever he does that yeah um so
i'm gonna go all the way back
and there are two people on planet earth
that
were given the singular task of making
sure you were loved and connected
and one if not both of them utterly and
drastically
not only failed that but they scorched
that and i want to tell you
on behalf of your community and your
friends i'm sorry that happened that
sucks
i think dads are not supposed to abuse
their daughters
no okay yeah
and i don't want to blame your mom i
don't know that situation and we don't
have time for that
but um
moms are supposed to be there to protect
their daughters too
okay and i want you to know all of that
sucks and i'm sorry that happened
second when you came out and talked
about this
what happened when did you decide to
talk about it
i actually didn't i my husband and i
started having kids and um
we started having daughters so so every
alarm you have in your
heart and mind set off right oh yeah
yeah
as soon as we found out we were having
girls it was yeah we knew we had to do
something and so
i we lived a long ways away from them so
i just we just had set up that he wasn't
allowed to come visit
and if he did he wasn't allowed to stay
at our house and he had to be around the
kids
only with us in the room we felt like we
could do a good job there but
after we had our second daughter my
husband was at work
was going to go back to work and i was
about to go back to work so i asked my
mom to come and help
when i went back to work and he then of
course
jumped in real quick and said he would
love to come up and help
and watch our girls
well and i we have never said anything
so
and i feel like i just don't have a lot
of courage whenever it comes to him so i
just texted him
and told him he wasn't welcome where we
were and then he apparently was confused
and showed the text to my mom
who had kind of maybe had an inkling
that something had gone on when i was a
kid but
she started quickly putting two and two
together so so listen
then it all came out your your
voice the words you are using are
classic
um language of somebody who has been
abused and traumatized by someone who
was supposed to love them
okay and do not please
please don't beat yourself up for things
like courage
for things like feeling afraid for
things like
feeling hurt please let yourself off the
hook for that
there is a little girl inside of you
that is still trying to protect you
okay and i want you to know she's done
her job
and it's time for her to go lay down
okay okay okay
and when you feel that feeling of and
your heart starts racing really hard
and you feel like you need to have a
hard conversation and you just
start to flinch i want you to exhale and
say
thank you sweetheart i've got it from
here and that's when
the rage-filled lauren can show up the
adult lauren who will
burn a house down for her baby girls
right
then she can show up okay okay
um so boundaries are important and we i
talk about boundaries a lot
um our friend henry cloud the master uh
the guy who wrote the
literally wrote the book called
boundaries talks a lot about the
importance of drawing boundaries
this is different this is nuclear
this is you will stay so far the hell
away from my family
and my children that if you sneeze in
this direction i'll call the cops on you
and i'll call him again
and i'll call him again yeah and here's
the thing i would
i just don't know he just seems like
he's not listening to that
that he people who are broken in the way
that he's broken and you if you've
listened to me enough you know i don't
like to use that term
child child predators people who prey on
children
people who abuse children sexually
they only respond to power that's it
yeah and they don't get inklings
because an inkling is a crack in the in
the concrete that they can slither into
they don't get suggestions because
suggestions
they they feel like vulnerability and
someone who preys on children
preys on vulnerability yeah
and so your brothers have you sat down
and had a real direct
hard conversation with them um well
i've told them everything because my
other brother also has a daughter
okay um they i feel like
they didn't know until about five years
ago and their world kind of came
crashing down i don't i haven't told
them what to do i've been trying to let
them kind of navigate that
have you have you explicitly told them
what happened
i emailed them i told them everything
okay yeah good for you
um i felt like i had to yeah i've sent
it to both of them
and i said i don't ever want to talk
about it again
you need this story is your story and
nobody is allowed to ask you questions
and force you to answer things you don't
want to answer this is your story your
narrative your world okay
um and i want you to always feel in
control of that narrative and when you
don't
that's when you i have control of part
two which is i'm walking away
okay so yeah um you control
the story okay but your brothers may
need some coaching
and as you mentioned if they had
idolized this man
and they had pumped him up and suddenly
they found something out about him
then they might need some guidance
however embarrassing that is
i wish they wouldn't need guidance i
wish they would have men in their life
that they could sit down and talk to who
would be straight with them
but here's the guidance that disgusting
man will never be involved in our family
get-togethers
if he knows where we are i am not going
to be there because my job is to protect
my heart and mind and my soul and my
daughters
your husband is going to step up and
help too because his job is to
love and honor and walk alongside and
protect you
and his daughters right and there is no
word mincing moving forward and i'm not
telling you what to do
i hope i'm empowering you that little
girl can finally
lay down and go play like she's supposed
to
yeah and freaking most the time
i live great like that my husband's
great and we live
a ways away from him but just even just
a couple
of maybe two weeks ago that's my
brothers came and said well what are we
supposed to say to dad whenever he
asked about you and i was like why is he
asking about me
he knows he's not supposed to have
anything to do with me but i was like
why do you even have
to ask yes i told them that they should
tell him to ask me
if they're if he wanted to know
something and he knows he's not allowed
to contact me but
so here's the thing give them a couple
of words to use which is
he y'all are not to speak on my behalf
to that disgusting person
my hope is that you would never talk to
him
he cashed out his father card
he gave it up yeah and he has done
nothing to redeem it nothing
no right no yep and so
um i would tell your brothers i don't
want to have a conversation with you
about that man
ever again ever and if any of you guys
give him our address
if you send him any photos of his
granddaughters
then i'm done with y'all too because you
have chosen a side
that is not one that i'm comfortable
with and there's a period at the end of
that sentence
okay and here's the thing i need you to
hear me directly when i say this
there wasn't something wrong with you as
a baby girl there was something wrong
with him
yeah there is nothing wrong with your
boundaries now
the problem remains with him okay
and i want to honor your brothers i know
it's confusing and it's easy on this
side of the fence to be like they should
just do
it's hard i get that but your brothers
have a responsibility and they need to
get it done
okay do you think if my dad had any
chance of ever
ever being redeemed like ever coming do
people like this
ever come around and if they ever would
what
i kind of felt like he might have to hit
rock bottom which is lose absolutely
everything
if he was ever going to look inside of
himself
but i thought that maybe he'd have to
lose his whole family
i believe strongly i mean the
cornerstone of why i do what i do is
because i believe in redemption
i believe there is no one person who
cannot
um with the help of a lot of other
people and
um with god and a lot of strength and a
lot of support
often professional help can't claw their
way back i believe that
i also know the data that says um
adult men who abuse young children
have a very very hard road back if they
ever want to come back
and it starts with a getting on your
face in the mud
and begging for forgiveness and being
completely honest and open and then
seeing
professional help for years and still
i'm
never going to leave that person alone
with my daughters period
no right i'm not going to have that
person to my house
period the relationship is forever
altered
because of what they did because of who
they chose to be
not you and those
who do that are master guilt trippers
you are the ones screwing up christmas
you're the one that wrecked my marriage
um you're the one that screwed up my
relationship with my sons
bull crap heat it
what you are having to do is put the
fire out
that he lit and that means you have to
stand on the front yard with the hose
and get everything wet and he set the
roof on fire but you're having to douse
the pictures and the couches
and the piano and the guitars you're
dusting everything because of a fire
he lit and what abusers do is they stand
in the front yard and say why did you
get my pictures all wet
because you set the fire dude right so
i do believe in redemption that is not
your story to walk
no i my brothers just ask and i
told them that i'm not the one who can
help him i know that for sure
and they're not the ones who can help
him either you don't think they can do
anything
absolutely not they keep thinking they
they're like well
i had asked him to go to counseling this
was myself years ago
and he went for like two two times and
he said it was way too hard it made him
cry he was so
sad
yes there she is
and then he quit so then that was when
we decided there was no hope for us
then he's a coward he is a coward and
he's not willing to do the work so is
there redemption possible for him
yep is he willing to do it nope
no okay nope okay and that is not
something your brothers can do and i
appreciate their heart man they love
their old man and they're trying to rack
their brains
i can't believe this happened um
but it is what it is okay what they can
do
and brothers out there listening to this
there are moments when our parents blow
our minds
i cannot believe my dad did that
here's their choice and i and if you
listen to my show at all you also know i
don't like binary choices either ors
i'm giving you an either or they can
choose
to double down on their sister
and to reconnect with you because you
probably have years and miles of pain
and disconnection that you're
going to be healing from for the rest of
your life and they can
love you and every time they reach out
to you and say hey what about dad
it hurts because you don't even have the
words for it and your body
falls apart from the inside out and
you're like what
and then you look in the mirror and
think you're crazy
yeah and so what they can do is they can
let him know
you hurt our family you imploded our
family because of your sickness
because of your choices to abuse our
sister
and my guess is you aren't the only one
that's my guess yeah i hope not but yeah
i know
i know the statistics but yeah and so
he chose that and until he chooses
to get a man to take to feel
uncomfortable in counseling
um for a couple of decades he should be
in jail quite honestly
and what i'll tell you this here's
here's a hard thing and we can wrap the
call up
okay the hard thing is this
if you know that he has access to kids
i will go to the police you have to
report i will go to the newspaper
i will tell everyone in the entire world
i've already
run it through my mind but running it
through your mind and actually doing it
are two different things
i would do it i already know for sure
that i would do it but
he did try once to have some kids around
him and my brothers completely flipped
out
and of course and then he stopped
uh flipping out is that step
that's step one a step one b
two three four and five is calling the
police
do you think i should call the police if
he even makes
like do you think i should have called
the police back whenever he
got a girlfriend who had granddaughters
yes
i i don't know when to yes i do i do
okay i absolutely do all right
and i don't have a lot of quarter for
this situation at all
okay um but yes and
if he reaches out to you i would call
the police if if he has a restraining
order if you have a straight order
against him i'd call the police
if he gets in contact with your brothers
and wants to go visit them and their
kids i'll call the police
and i would tell your brothers every
time i know that he's at your house
around kids i'm gonna call the police
okay if you want to make a police record
about your childhood
depending on what your state you're in
there may not even be a statute of
limitations on that deal
there's not i already looked that might
give you
a step towards healing because he's not
getting the message
yeah and every time he tries to ask
about you it's a power move
every time he sends you a letter it's a
power move
okay and he will only respond to
somebody look at me
do i i kind of thought i said i kind of
thought about being like you won't leave
us alone we should tell the police but
then i thought they'd just laugh because
it was like
he sent you a letter ma'am you're fine i
don't know
if you go to a sex crime investigator
who knows what they're doing and you go
to a sex crimes advocate
who knows what historical trauma does to
to children
and how that ricochets through their
life for the rest of their life
they'll hear you and they won't laugh at
you okay
they'll honor you they'll honor your
story and
at at best they can go to his house
and go through his stuff and open an
investigation
at worst they've got him on record yeah
so if he shows up at somebody else's
house again
then people can get involved okay
all right but i want you here's the
thing though you don't have to
yell and scream and fuss and fight this
is your story and your narrative
if you see see that he's around kids you
do you have a responsibility
i'm putting that on you but i will um i
want you to
never lose control of the narrative
again
of your story of who you choose to tell
it to how you choose to tell it that's
yours
okay okay you've had enough people in
your life take your power away
yeah and i'm glad that you got a husband
who loves you you got two baby girls
that
you you love dearly and
um i hope that you can
can be honest and direct with your
brothers in a way that they can now
understand
oh we've got to pick we've got to take a
side
okay all right is that cool
hey thank you for trusting me with a
call yeah thank you
that was helpful you're a brave brave
woman lauren
and you've got a long road of healing i
want you to make sure
you are doing the work to be healed too
make sure you get with a good trauma
therapist who can walk alongside you
give you some tools for when that spins
up in you
give you some tools to walk alongside if
you do choose to call the police on your
dad
who will walk alongside you and may even
be in the room with you when you decide
to meet with your brothers
may give you some language to talk to
your husband and more importantly give
you some language to talk to yourself
but as i started the call i want you to
let that little girl who's been
protecting you for years and years and
years i want you to let her go out and
play
and i want you to let that healing begin
all right so here's the deal
so i was just talking to lauren and now
i'm talking to you
if you know of somebody who's abusing
children
and that somebody's in your home that
somebody's in your church that
somebody's in your workplace
you have to call you've got to get
involved
it's not by your hand but in your lap
somebody dropped a grenade in your lap
and you've got to deal with it
and it sucks and it's uncomfortable and
you have to do it
if you are hurting children
stop
stop you are lighting a forest fire in
the heart and soul
of a young person that will never be
extinguished you are
choosing through your own selfishness
and sickness to destroy a person
stop
if you have a brother or sister that you
find that was abused by somebody you
loved
call them go meet with them in person
and tell them that you love them
that you are so sorry this happened
and ask them how can i connect with you
they don't need your advice they don't
need your recommendations
they need you to shut your mouth and be
connected to them
and to say i love you and i'm so sorry
what can i do to help
normally we wrap up the show with a song
hey james i want to kill it
um ending the show today with song
lyrics doesn't sound like the right
thing to do
sucks people hurt your kids
today's show is heavy and
i want everyone to know there is
peace out there there is healing out
there however hard it is
if your parents died tragically
your father who abused you won't leave
you and your new girls alone
[Music]
there is hope and peace out there get
with people
who will walk alongside you and i want
you to know
you are worth being well
it may suck getting there but you're
worth it
this is the dr john baloney show
you